hey everyone and welcome back to game
Sports coverage of e3 2019 joining me on
the stage is my co-host Michael Hadi and
we're very excited to speak with Bill
brosman and Sean s guy to talk about
Marvel's Avengers welcome yes finally
we've unleashed Marvel's Avengers upon
the true believers of the world I was
gonna say so you announced the game a
good few years ago now I remember that
little teaser trailer offering a little
hint and then at the square Enix press
conference yesterday finally lifted the
lid what's it what's it been like to
have that fan reaction it's incredible
you see the fans just won lose their
stuff when they see it and then have all
these speculations about how it works
who's in it how it plays and those are
kind of the questions we wanted and it
was a bit overwhelming for us on the
stage actually it was just like okay let
them share coz we had it all planned and
then we go out there and their energy
just just changed and they devolved into
the presentation yeah I saw which is
great so you just go off script because
you you you know Sean said we've been
we've been working on it for so long and
and and even on the trailer itself
working on it and watching it so many
times and we it's so funny we saw it
just a few hours before but seeing it
when we're standing backstage and
hearing a roar of the audience at
certain points it changed the whole
experience for us and we're like they
like it they like it it was a very
theatrical reveal right I guess you'd
expect nothing less with like an
Avengers game but can you guys give us
like a top down broad view of like what
the game will be like I sit down to play
it over a weekend or a week or something
what will it be like what's the rhythm
of the game like well there's there's a
core campaign right and then you have
the coop right so the core campaign I
think it's something new so in that
quote campaign that's heavy story
there's a very deep narrative in there
and you will be playing along with that
character that sports will push that
narrative
and that intervals in that structure
you'll be able to go off into missions
as your favorite hero as you unlock them
throughout this campaign you also have
the option to play that initial setup
and then be released into the
multiplayer world where you can play
with your friends and you know up to
four characters at a time so it all
depends on how you want to experience it
but there's a really awesome strong
campaign strong story that sets up the
world sets up the characters so that you
understand what you're you know what the
stakes are when you do go into say the
co-op game so it's an only storyline and
obviously we just had something very
similar with Marvel spider-man last year
taking these characters that we know and
love so well and putting in game studios
being allowed to put their own twist on
it what's it been like was he like an
engine it what's great is that there's
so much Avengers material to look at and
we looked at it all we went back we
looked at 60 years of Avengers main
series and spin-offs we look at the
cartoon we looked at the films and
you're right we wanted to present to the
players an all-new original story so
that if they're a longtime fan there'll
be a ton of Easter eggs but if they've
just seen a few movies are retread a few
comments or I have seen nothing it's
really accessible they can jump right in
and we're gonna leave them guessing
where it's gonna where it's gonna go
next but it's so fun to to you know to
collaborate with crystal and and ask
them what kind of image of story do you
want to tell yeah and Marvel's a great
collaborator like there's so much like
well we're saying to choose from right
and then you know having someone like
Bill to just give us all the history of
it go deeper than the surface you know
stuff that you know when I thought I was
a fan and I met Belle I'm like no this
is a super fan right and then you get
all this information and you have a lot
of to pull it deep narrative out of you
know all the history all the
you know small little elections or
differences between these characters and
bring that to life it's been my pleasure
I've been working for Marvel for 21
years now and reading comics non-stop
since I was six so I better know this
stuff why we brought you on stage yeah
and talk about it on stage so it's it's
interesting because I guess anytime you
adopt a huge property like this we just
had respawn on the stage earlier and you
know they're they're kind of have a
similar challenge with oh now we have
Star Wars what do we do with it how do
you mind I nameks past and like Shawn I
know your past working on like Uncharted
Lost Legacy these 3d action adventures
how do you mine your portfolio of games
figure out how to put that into an
Avengers format well you know I think
it's for me the key is always story
right I think this is a passion we share
really strongly Marvel and Crystal and
the studio right it's it's kind of the
heartbeat at everything that we do and
like I said drawing from these
characters adding the spectacle that you
expect from Marvel right but then
keeping a very deep strong story which
you also expect for Marvel it's kind of
in the DNA of you know the partnership
which is why it works so well like
Marvel wants it we wanted and we're
merging it and still trying to keep that
on the stick feel right like so that you
feel like the Hulk so that you feel like
Iron Man so let me feel like soar and
not lose that while we're trying to just
you know get the story in it's a great
Mary and a great challenge so exactly
when we when we do a Marvel team-up with
a collaborator we always look for
someone who has vision who has the
talent and most importantly has the
passion and Krystal and the teams have
that in spades and and we care so much
about story yeah story is at the heart
of everything we do
and when you have that magic combination
of talent story gameplay and the passion
of all the teams together yeah and the
magic the fans are in the studio right
those are the fans - this is a game you
know by fans for
fans right so you know they won't let me
sleep I guarantee it right they'll tell
me hey just you know this isn't your
right this doesn't look right you know
we get it from all sides right so it's
great it's great to see it
so I mean speaking our fans the reaction
at the showcase yesterday not only to
get him see these characters in a brand
new game but the reaction when you came
out and said this game is going to be
supported with content and yes it's
gonna be free no loot boxes can you talk
about you know perhaps your
decision-making process when it came to
planning ahead for the future and how
fans are gonna be able to I mean is
there a kind of roadmap where I know
obviously Marvel hasn't announced the
new slate of movies we know a couple
that are coming are they're gonna be
direct tie-ins or is it going to be just
you know content that you guys think
makes sense in regards to the story that
you're telling I will say this we have a
roadmap of characters that we would like
to introduce into the game and regions
and really again it's number one it's
about the game itself
what mix of characters what new
characters do people want we heard
people yelling last night okay
and that was easy stay tuned true
believers yeah it's not done it's never
expanding right we're gonna it's going
to be a continuous game all right so we
have opportunities to add new characters
you know play with different storylines
and that's the thing that we're super
excited about so yeah soon become will
see and soon be review we are digging
deep into the roster yes we're thinking
about what are the immediate picks that
people will want and then we're like
let's go back into the back issues and
what about this character I think you
guys can do a really awesome version of
that so we want to surprise people with
the characters that will join well
that's what I was curious about because
just by definition the Avengers is an
ensemble cast right previous games like
Crystal Dynamics things that stick out
or Lara Croft a very like a revered
character in her own right and very
difficult to write when she has so many
fans I imagine but this like it's like
how do you get it's almost a challenge
that the Marvel Cinematic Universe that
is how do you bring all these people
together but still make each of their
arcs
meaningful yeah and then it is the same
challenge we have right and play it as
well how do you make their character
arts
you know meaningful how to make their
play meaningful how do you get enough
time with each character to understand
them feel them decide which one's your
favorite right how you level them up so
it is a continuous challenge but I think
you guys would be pretty pretty excited
to see what we're doing and and the
beautiful baked-in thing about the
Avengers is you know at its core the
wish fulfillment is assembling and if
you look at the history of the Avengers
you go back decades and their stories
what they do is they they have that
wishes one that you want of we're
different we come from different worlds
so the Avengers has the history of
bringing in different races different
ethnicities different genders characters
who used to be villains then become
heroes for the Avengers and when they
get together they may disagree and
that's okay because when a hole is
ripped in the sky and hell is pouring
down the Avengers will stand together
and they have each other's back and that
is the fantasy that we all want in this
game and in real life you want to come
together with groups and say hey we have
different backgrounds we have different
skills different abilities we may even
disagree but I got your back so what I'm
playing and getting together my friends
to play online is there gonna be you
know a character lock system there's not
gonna be you know three Iron Man's and
and a black widow or is it you know
everybody gets one you don't need you
can only have one Iron Man at a time so
you will be playing as four five four of
the core but as you progress and unlock
different looks for the heroes
your team of Avengers and your Iron Man
may be totally different from my team of
Avengers and my Iron Man we're gonna
have costumes uh uniforms based on you
know original we have original all new
costumes we're gonna have costumes based
on previously existing looks that you've
seen in the comics so you're it's gonna
be your Avengers you can put together
the team you want you get to level them
up you get to decide how they look you
get
I think a question for me is that so
last year obviously we lost the great
Stanley Stan the man Stan the man
however we know that he did record a lot
of you know cameos he was in endgame
he was reference was there any
opportunity for him to record something
for the game well we can't let you add
some talk about that right now but
obviously I mean we grew up reading the
words of Stan not only standing but the
art of Jack Kirby and Jambi Simha and
Jenner mita and so without them we
wouldn't be here they are are they are
our heroes you know we stand on their
shoulders and I mean I would say the
whole thing is is a tribute to their
work all right well Shawn bill thank you
so much for joining us we appreciate it
thanks your time hey hey true believers
out there we want to thank you for last
night for watching the trailer your
energy was awesome all the comments were
hearing we're listening to them yep
sharing happy we're taking it back to
the studios we're listening to you thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]